depuis la violente agression du militant
indépendantiste yvan colonna en prison
la colère ne faiblit pas encore la
tension est forte très forte dans l'île
de beauté nuits d'émeutes en corse
dimanche des milliers de personnes se
sont rassemblées à bastia pour protester
et demander le rapatriement divan
colonna sur le sol corse des
manifestations qui habite tourné aux
émeutes
[Musique]
face à la situation de mini gérald
darmanin a décidé de se rendre sur l'île
de beauté pour tenter d'apaiser les
tensions il a aussi évoqué au journal
corse-matin la possibilité de leur
accorder une autonomie alors êtes vous
pour ou contre l'indépendance de la
corse ce soir tony nous explique
pourquoi il souhaite l'autonomie de la
corse et il réagit aux images chocs
[Musique]
ça va ou pas je suis se voir mais bon
chez nous c'est dur je sais je sais qu
est ce qui se passe en ce moment en
corse et chaussées chaud et ce qui se
passait mais coûte
l'état s'est mal comporté et s'est passé
pas le peuple français et a comparé deux
choses il ya l'état français et le
peuple français bien sûr donc là encore
sur notion france est ce parce que yvan
colonna est entre la vie et la mort fait
donc je vais d'abord rendre hommage à la
famille colonna que je connais très très
bien d'ailleurs jugé au ballon et que
lui et son frère je connais sa soeur
mais le problème c'est que nous on n'a
pas l'air vraiment choqué et peiné
parce que même s'il serait très très
vite et bien sûr sur peut être évitée
parce que si si l'état avait fait son
travail et avait
demandé à ce que les détenus corses
soient à à borgo par exemple les
familles n'étaient plus près bon on voit
la sécurité ont dit des ps tu peux pas
aller à borgo parce que la sécurité
recul hier mans surveiller et en fin de
compte il se retrouve avec un guide à
east qu'il assassine c'est un assassinat
il faut comprendre tous les corps sont
choqués même ma mère qui à 90 ans
qui est le gaulliste un des chocs est
donc une toile les jeunes corses alors
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
sont les jeunes qui sont les plus
touchés par ce qui se passe là bas y'a
pas que les jeux bon les jeunes tu les
connais les jeunes ils vont dehors et
c'est normal après tu vois pas ma mère
90 ans dans la rue mais automatiquement
ils sont tous choqués passe chez nous
c'est très important yvan colonna il a
fait ce qu'il a fait
c'est sûr que alors il paraît que c'est
un détenu modèle il vont mener tous
alessandri et ferrandi sont détenus
évadés elles ce sont des gens qui ont
pris et ça fait 24 ans qui sont en
prison aux trente ans quand je vois par
exemple excuse moi non mais comme sap et
le landais là le long des rues lalande
est il a violé peut-être une gosse la
tuer l'ennui dans un trou et pas qu'une
aile et loire d'autres crimes de crime
et le mec dans 22 ans il peut peut-être
sortir ils ont tué le préfet on a
condamné fermement on n'est pas donc
autant qu on endort rend hommage aussi à
la famille erignac mais a certainement
donné 24 ans c'est le temps de prison
toné de la chance quand même à à ce
qu'ils puissent au moins rentrer en
course ils voient leur famille ça fait
20 ans que les familles
les billets d'avion et s'est fait
surtout pour la sécurité il aurait dû
être en corse même incarcéré en corse
wallace aurait été tranquille non mais
c'est pour ça qu'on l'a pas mis dans une
prison corps justement parce qu'on avait
peur aussi de la sécurité sur
wii mais c'est ça c'est l'état qui le
dit oui parce que les saisonniers qui
sont des prisonniers qui sont encore à
bordeaux il ya des voyous il ya des
délinquants il s'évade par un échange
ils sont détenus
donc quand on laisse une personne huit
minutes ce dans une salle de gym
c'est quand même se dit mme ce qui s'est
passé en fait à côté nous avec un parfum
de contre colonna est
il un statut particulier donc on le
surveille qui les dps il va faire du
temps finalement tu vas faire du sport
il se retrouve avec une personne
qui ne
doit pas être ici qui est un idéaliste
que eu des gros soucis
avec
dans sa vie et la grèce colonna il
s'avère qu'il s'est servi aux
particuliers parce qu'ils ont eue si tu
veux que l'on n'a l'a dit je suis laïc
et l'autre
c'est parti en vrille donc
automatiquement
non ils ont fait une agressive et lui a
mis un sac de plastique il a été là elle
a étouffé avec rigole pendant 8 minutes
où sont les mecs tout son gardien le mec
il est surveillé
donc je pense que là tout le monde ça
symbole les rignac c'est un symbole
que l'on a ça a été un symbole c'est un
malheur pour ces deux familles la
famille colonna je les connais très bien
c'est une famille extraordinaire lepers
un ancien diplomate le le frère je joue
au ballon et que lui je vais vous mêmes
et qui vend je connais sa soeur ce sont
des gens bien il faut pas faire croire
que c'est des racailles des voyous mais
j'étais à émerger bon là fait ce qu'il a
fait on a condamné il fallait pas le
faire bien sûr mais là cette amende et
tu vas pas lui faire payer il a fait 20
ans de prison j'aimerais justement qu'on
explique à nos téléspectateurs la
différence re indépendance et autonomie
gilles verdez alors l'autonomie vous
rester dans le cadre de la république
française et l'état continue
d'administrer ce qu'on appelle les
pouvoirs régaliens c'est-à-dire police
justice armée et la monnaie d'accord si
c'est l'indépendance vous quittez la
république française vous quitté l'union
européenne donc de fait vous quitter la
zone euro et vous devenez un pays qui
s'appelle la corse et qui s'administre a
entièrement qui pourra changer le nom
éventuellement en toute indépendance
voilà vous voulez quoi vous tenir
l'autonomie
indépendante c'est vrai et bien sûr
c'est très bien que j'ai kiffé tu fais
un référendum demain malgré que les
choses ne changent évoluent ou ont
évolué parce que l'état fait pas son
travail donc tous ces jeunes ils ne
peuvent plus ils sortent des universités
ils sortent de des écoles ya pas de
travail rien sur mesure à pied sur le
continent moi je me rappelle j'avais 15
ans a réalisé 17 ans on se retrouver
dans la rue la même chose que c'était
une autre époque d'un an ça devient de
plus en plus difficile donc on ne veut
pas l'indépendance la dépendance est
chose mais on peut y arriver si on ne
fait pas ce qu'il faut alors emmanuel
macron a changé d'avis en quatre ans ce
qu'en 2010 utilité totalement
essentiellement austin oui voilà un
élément dans chéri à l'autonomie
complètement hostile et là ça a l'air
d'évoluer mais m'excuse mois avant la
musique à 26 jours avant les élections
ouais je pense c'est un peu bizarre faut
reconnaître à corps donc être plus
intelligente on la table la pâte ou même
dans le public dans le public si
oui je sais très bien que même s'il joue
avant ils prennent la décision non
seulement
48 en 48 heures les dps existe plus d'un
sur deux 48 heures donc pour la violence
pour se faire à entendre c'était celle
que les élus ça fait cinq ans que les
élus disent il faut faire faire venir
les ai prises une politique en corse non
non non non ils ont attendu attendu et
26 jours avant les élections moi j'ai
rien contre macro ni macro ni sarkozy ni
en hollande
ça fait 40 ans que ça dure ça fait 40
ans que ça dure
sarkozy d'ailleurs qui apparemment
nicolas sarkozy qui devrait apporter son
soutien à co président sortant demain ou
après demain on allait dans les
prochains mois c'est un coup d'arrêt qui
voit là oui voilà donc c'est ça ça sera
un gros coup oui une voiture donc là
j'ai une question pour anthony c'est
vous dit effectivement l'état fait pas
son travail on veut l'autonomie parce
que là on est dans la rue on n'a pas de
travail pas tout ça mais si vous étiez
autonome en quoi l'art il faut courir à
plus de travail pourquoi irais plus de
travail pourquoi tout d'un coup les gens
seraient plus dans la rue pourquoi ça
serait amusant je suis d'accord avec toi
mais ce qu'il faut comprendre tu prends
par l'argent les bretons les basques
mais tu te retournes son accord c'est
bibi beaucoup de touristes la ruralité
tous les villages on ne s'en occupe pas
il ya des jeunes bergers ils font du
fromage du miel mais sûr il ya eu 200
l'agriculture on a été
félicitée des corps et on a eu des
médias de partout il ya des jeunes qui
se battent il faut les aider donc autant
à saint-amand de données on est dans une
île bien sûr difficile pour nous c'est
vrai des transports l'avion point
d'avion mais vous quand vous descendez
en corse d'ailleurs il coûte cher alors
qu'on en comptait territoria et ce n'est
pas la faute que de l'état français ait
eu des élus pendant 40 ans
des clans qui n'ont pas fait leur
travail voilà je sais quelles actions de
ceux de dalsa c'est là qu'il ya des
bretons et revendiquent pour leur région
nous c'est la même chose mais nous c'est
une spécificité c'est une île en plus tu
te remettre les cours je vois beaucoup
de caractère de personnalités on est un
peu excuse moi de te dire comme les
juifs en alabama on a le père la mère
les très respectueux de la famille des
personnes âgées des femmes et des
enfants nous c'est important ces
valeurs-là d'encadrer les jeunes ils ne
peuvent plus non plus rien du tout vous
voyez pas que les jeunes qui sont dans
la rue sont des casseurs croyez moi
maintenant on est contre la violence on
est tous content à 64 ans je vais pas
aller dans la violence mais a
certainement donné à 48 heures ils ont
réussi à avoir ce que les élus n'ont pas
pu avoir en cinq ans bon macron génie
juin contre macro et un arrêt les c'est
une politique qui date depuis 40 ans
darmanin descend aujourd'hui il va se
retrouver en saas d'élus quand la
bouteille quand commun qui connaissent
la corde depuis 40 ans il arrive le pot
darmanin on l'envoie le bûcher le pot et
bella malin c'est un jeunot dans le
politique et la rive en bas il va se
faire manger par les élus corses et oui
je dis va se faire manger lorsque la
barre arrivons à moi j c'est une image
et je n'ouvre il fait beau c'est quoi
ces toiles des sachets lui aimerait
faire passer le dernier message à faire
passer on a déjà le premier message que
veut faire passer mais c'est comme pour
les autres détenus chacun doit se
trouver dans la région tu sais qu'en
france le la pénitentiaire cela plus
terribles du monde les catastrophes mais
le temps disons le pays des droits de
l'homme maintenant les gens ils ont fait
tout rond quand les mecs ont fait vingt
ans 24 ans et là nous regarde d'ailleurs
un il faut nous regarde il faut laisser
passer quand même dans une deuxième
chance bien sûr et bien sûr qu'on
condamne la certains préféreront peut
pas accepter ça mais à sincèrement
donner tous ces jeunes
crois moi j'ai mon petit cousin qui
s'est pris une grenade en tête
bon il devait pas se trouver là mais oui
mais il ya un point de mairie sa femme
est employée de mairie j'appelle marco
bon il est descendu parce qu'il s'est
dit bon il faut qu'on bouge y avait des
personnes des idées des gens de 40 ans
de 50 ans il ya pas que des jeunes après
les jeunes csu ses plus hauts les jeunes
surtout l'école les jeunes à n'importe
quelle manifestation il faut qu'ils
fassent aussi de
ils en ont marre des gens peuvent plus
je te jure c'est très très chaud